hello everyone and welcome to the
coronavirus
virtual webinar series my name is
shanali paul
i'm the ceo of cloudlimbs.com
i'm here to present on the topic setting
up a coronavirus
clinical diagnostic testing lab limbs
for automation
and data management please feel free to
submit questions during the presentation
and i will send you replies as soon as i
can
today we are going to talk about the
need for rapid testing of covert 19
or the novel coronavirus infectious
disease
the importance in containing the
pandemic
the challenges in testing the sars kovi
ii or the virus that causes covert 19
and in the end how a lab manager can
overcome these challenges
by using a limbs and thereby increase
the response to the need for testing
samples
as new cases emerge
as we already know laboratories around
the world
are in a race against time trying to
increase the testing of covert 19 cases
and isolate the positives in order to
control the spread
the fact that covert 19 spreads easily
makes the case for swift
and large amount of testing or mass
testing
detecting the disease allows for quick
isolation of such cases
and reduces the chances of new
infections
significantly so how did this all start
the novel coronavirus is commonly
believed to have originated
from a bat and only known to be in
animals
the virus is known to have jumped to
humans in rohan
in china and began spreading at a fresh
seafood market
it belongs to the same family as the
sars or the severe
acute respiratory syndrome and mers
or the middle east respiratory syndrome
coronaviruses
that emerge in 2003 and 12.
we already know that it is more
contagious than the common flu
and the modern the modes of transmission
include touching of contaminated
surfaces
or from infected individuals studies
have shown that the virus
is airborne and can spread through
sneezing and coughing
since it is a new virus previously only
known in animals
the human immune system is unable to
identify it
as a threat symptoms for the virus can
range from dry
cough runny nose muscle pain
skin rashes to diarrhea nausea
and high fever different drugs and
therapies are being used to combat the
virus
however at this time there are no
established treatments
or vaccines available although we all
know that
trials are in place in a rush to produce
one
at the time of this presentation uh
there are over
7.2 million cases of food 19
spread over 2 spread over to
213 countries and territories worldwide
the united states brazil russia
spain united kingdom and india are
leading in the number of infections
as you can see the curve for the daily
increase
in cases is growing alarmingly about
127 000 a day there is an
urgent need for aggressive testing in
order to isolate the positives
for checking the spread of the disease
the emphasis is on testing
so as to convert the current situation
to a slow pandemic
or for flattening the curve so that it
does not put
undue pressure on the healthcare system
the chart here is taken from a study
conducted by
johns hopkins university it shows the
projected growth of the coronavirus
over june
2019 corona virus
if not checked can potentially alter the
global landscape
and change the way of life as they say
we are already living in the new normal
one of the best ways to curve the spread
is via social distancing use of masks in
public
frequent washing of hands with soap and
the use of sanitizers
equally important is to exercise and
lead a healthy and active lifestyle
with strong lungs however in addition to
prevention
testing for identifying and isolating
positives is of paramount
importance so that the healthy
individuals are protected
and the spread is restricted so here's
the case
for testing testing and more testing
the virus is highly contagious it
spreads from one person to the other
factoring in multiple studies the r
naught of the covert 19 is estimated to
be between
1.4 and 2.5 which means
one infected individual in the absence
of any mitigation
can infect between two to three
individuals
now this seems like a small number but
when you look at it this way
one infects two two infects four
four eight and eight in fact sixteen the
growth
is exponential the seasonal flu
has an r naught of about one
while most people start showing symptoms
in four to five days
after getting infected every one in four
cases can be asymptomatic
this means that such individuals have no
visible signs of the infection
but are potential carriers and can
spread the virus
these individuals could be potential
contact tracing nightmares
if such an individual is not quickly
tested
and identified and the only way to
identify
such a person is to test and then
isolate them
the virus has an incubation period of 14
days
this gives a large window to spread if
the
infected person is not isolated with the
current strain on the health care system
and the number of severe cases rising
isolating
each positive has become the need of the
art
isolation and contact tracing would be
even more challenging
in densely populated countries such as
india
aggressive testing is important for
identifying the positives
and isolating them so that healthcare
facilities are not overloaded with
patients
and there are no capacity of beds or
ventilators
or staff to tend to them
so even so that the turnaround times
have been slow
due to a variety of factors from lack of
in-house trained staff
to parsity of laboratory resources to
handle high volumes of tests
and slower than expected test production
to actually getting diagnostic assays
that are rapid
and still accurate in their diagnosis
the challenge is that the
testing labs have been enormous as more
and more point of care test kits are now
becoming
available around the globe including in
the united states
as a part of fda's emergency use
authorization process
or eua process in short one
bottleneck appears to be easing up
while we understand that rapid testing
is important
many countries have not been able to
keep up with the demands of testing
one of the reasons of course is not
enough labs are equipped with testing
of such contagious specimens and those
which
are they're facing numerous challenges
in these times recruiting staff
experience and handling infectious
specimens
is a challenge if experienced staff is
not available
training needs to be scheduled so
following sop
safety practices and handling infectious
samples
and testing is of paramount importance
testing kits are already limited
and any mistakes will lead to a wastage
in time and energy
and would have consequences for both the
patient
and their families a lab needs to
standardize
and validate new test methods and as
they evolve
even before testing forward 19 specimens
having the test methods in place is
vital to the functioning of the lab
getting supplies such as reagents
equipments
personal protective equipment has been a
challenge
with these available in short supply due
to these
unprecedented times meeting compliance
is another challenge
particularly that of hipaa thea and iso
15189 therefore us has mandated that the
tests be conducted
in clia certified labs the instruments
used
in testing also play a vital role in the
accuracy of the results
they need to be properly calibrated and
if not
they could potentially lead to a false
positive
or even worse a false negative
keeping track of the instrument
maintenance and calibration schedules
is of paramount importance fighting this
pandemic is like a race against time
and to win this race we need to ramp up
testing
and reduce turnaround time
the way to overcome the challenges we
just discuss
is to build an automation pipeline using
robotics
and to use informatics tools such as
limbs
at university of california berkeley at
its
innovative genomics institute
they rapidly repurposed a 2500 square
foot uh scientific lab
into an automatic into an automated uh
diagnostic laboratory the facility was
testing thousand samples a day and with
a robust
robotics pipeline and informatics
support
the daily testing could be ramped up to
3 000 samples a day
so this is the power of automation and
informatics
that we are about to discuss in the
coming slides
in a typical lab setup and it may vary
from one lab to another a clinician
registers
as a client in the limbs this
registration helps him register
samples with the testing facility
a test request is sent and the samples
are shipped to the facility
the lab manager receives the request
accepts it
receives the samples stores them and
then assigns a qualified technician
to conduct the test the test results are
recorded
validated by a supervisor and then
reported in a pre-approved
format templated as per cdc and fda
guidelines in the us
the samples are then removed from the
facility
after a stipulated number of days
so how does the limbs help in automation
a limb has sample management
test management workflow management
personnel management
instrument management data management
it can generate reports and meet
compliance
and we shall discuss these in the
upcoming slides
so how does uh limbs manage samples
now laboratories are receiving a deluge
of samples
there are um in these times and managing
the samples
is an odorless job for them with the
limbs
it may not be each sample received can
be
tracked through its life cycle in the
lab right from the time it is received
the sample metadata is stored in the
system
as it moves through different processes
the sample status is maintained
whether it is being received in the lab
or if it is being stored
or if it is under testing or a result is
already available
at the same time as it passes from one
custodian to another
an order trail is maintained the lims
therefore
serves as a guide for not only
maintaining the sample data
but also in understanding where in the
laboratory workflow the sample is
sample tracking also is in can prove to
be a challenge
uh if the limbs is not available
after the sample is received it may be
lost
if the storage location of the received
sample is not maintained
a lims provides a virtual storage setup
and
enables visualization of the sample
location
so at any given time if the sample is
not being processed
the lab person will know exactly where
it is stored
and therefore from where it can be
retrieved
we all know that sample data without
patient information is incomplete
a lims maintains the patient's age
medical history
lifestyle details comorbidities
which may help clinicians to raise a
flag so when a sample comes in
a limbs enables the administrator to be
identified
the sample by assigning an internal
sample id
an anonymization is a part of hipaa
and with the stigma surrounding cohort
this could prove to be a useful tool in
the current scenario
so in short all personally identifiable
information
is blanked out as you see from the
process
in the third column which means the phi
can be made accessible
only to personnel that have the rights
to access
it a digital signature is required
before unmasking of the data
in line with the 21 cfr party level
the other challenge is to track the
tag or the turnaround time for a test
if the start and the end time of a test
is available
the lims calculates the tat and then it
flags the tests
that lie outside the expected part this
functionality enables
lab managers to track the efficiency of
the lab
and take steps in removing the
bottlenecks that affect the data
the factors that can be affecting the
that would be
inadequate inventory delayed approval
processes
staff competency or training
requirements and these can be
effectively
addressed by the lab manager to bring
the tax within acceptable limits
one of the primary requirements of a
diagnostic lab
is generating reports so a lims allows
laboratories to easily report
the test results using a list a labview
design multiple reporting templates
and meet reporting requirements easily
you can add drafts flags
flags your logos signatures
you can insert comments on the
observations and report
and meet the reporting guidelines said
by the government bodies
such as fda and cdc if you're in the us
here is a report displaying results from
a quantitative
elisa test
a lens can help you shift the reporting
to your clients
online and help them access information
through a secure and flexible portal
after configuring the
catalogs and tests for the services you
offer
uh they can be made available for
selection through a client portal
clinicians clinicians can log in to the
client portal submit samples
and specify the tests to be performed
since you know that the tests are
requested
provisions can be made to accommodate
the request
clinicians can get time real-time access
to
sample analysis processes get
notified when the reports are available
in a quick easy and secure process the
reports can be securely downloaded from
the portal
typically a 128-bit encryption is
employed
for a secure transfer after the reports
are accepted
the invoices can also be delivered
electronically
this automation eliminates paper reports
brings down customer service calls and
saves time spent on handling
status related questions from clients
freeing up your staff time and saving
resources a major requirement of a lab
is to maintain stock uh imagine having a
bunch of tests to perform
but running out of testing kits or even
worse
ppe's or masks or gloves
running out of even one of such items
can dramatically bring down the number
of tests
that can be conducted on any given day
the lens enables you to keep track of
inventory
for those running low it sends an alert
to the lab
manager so that it can uh quickly
take stock and place an order since the
lead times are higher than usual
in these unprecedented times it is
advisable to keep the thresholds higher
so that your stocks are replenished
even before you run out of them
a laboratory needs to ensure that the
equipment used for conducting the test
is well maintained and properly
calibrated
without which the results cannot be
assured
a lens maintains a list of equipment
their spare components
and it keeps talk of the spares so that
you always
have those in case an instrument breaks
down it keeps track of the technician
responsible
for the equipment it maintains the date
on which
the maintenance took place and schedules
upcoming maintenance and calibration
dates the lab manager receives the
reminder ahead of time
so that lab activities can be scheduled
for maintenance days
you can also add purchase information
such as model name and number
serial number warranty period purchase
date
and the vendor contact information
one of the chief jobs of williams is
to integrate with instruments that are
available in the lab
so primarily for maintaining data
integrity
and for maintaining efficiency in the
lab
a limbs should upload time span reports
being generated by these instruments so
that time is not lost in
entering the information manually and
the
results reported are accurate rt pcr
systems such as those which are
currently being used
uh from hologic and from abbott uh
are used for covert 19 testing it is
imperative for you
to have your limbs integrated with such
systems
and other point of care equipment so
that
it helps maintain data integrity avoids
costly errors
saves time and resources
now laboratories have several documents
these could be
sops test methods instruction manuals
lab notes and they need to be centrally
available for all
uh staff working on the test
all the staff needs access to the latest
versions to the sops and manuals
so a lims helps maintain and track all
the documents
the version numbers and the date of
modification
furthermore you can easily associate
these documents with
tests and instruments such as the
current scenario when protocols
are constantly changing as we learn
something new
each day new guidelines emerge well we
need to ensure that the latest version
is
associated with the covert tests for all
the staff to follow
if the older version is used by any
chance
the results cannot be approved and a
retest would have to be conducted
losing time as well as wasting resources
one of the most important resource
available to a lab manager is this
staff or personnel a lims helps you keep
track of
the staff's technical competence and
helps identify
training needs a lims helps you manage
staff records along with their education
qualification training technical
knowledge
skills and experience knowing this
information
a lab manager can identify additional
training requirements
for handling the current situation for
example
using biosafety cabinets or handling
hazardous specimens
it helps manage different pieces of
training required
for the staff these trainings can then
be assigned and marked as complete
when they are done such trainings also
help identify
the staff that are confident to be
assigned
uh the testing of forward samples a
limbs will stop you from
assigning testing to staff still
undergoing training
it will also help you identify resources
that are trained
but are not yet assigned a job which
means you can use your resources to your
maximum capacity
so to summarize a lims
helps you easily track a sample's
journey in the lab
right from collection till disposal it
ensures patient confidentiality
and enables following hipaa guidelines
it integrates with instruments to load
accurate test results
with ease uh it helps manage
instruments their maintenance and
calibration schedules
as well as integrates with instruments
to
maintain data integrity
it also maintains quality measures via
proper documentation
and staff training it also helps
you generate custom test reports that
comply with
federal reporting guidelines
thank you for your time and attention
today
and as a reminder i'm happy to take
questions
please email them to lab roots or to the
email address provided on this slide
and i will reach out to each one of you
personally
thank you once again